there's been a mistake in transporting
patients to the USNS comfort that's
docked in New York and therefore there
are now coronavirus cases that have been
brought onto that hospital ship Lucas
Tomlinson broke this story a couple of
hours ago from the Pentagon eek picks up
our coverage from there hi Lucas hi Lena
and I'm told the number of Crona virus
cases brought onboard the ship was less
than five the Navy says this isn't a
mistake but proof the protocols have put
in place are working in a statement the
Navy said quote while admitting patients
who were transferred to USNS comfort for
treatment a few patients tested positive
for covin 19 the comfort has infection
control procedures that are followed
just like hospitals ashore our medical
experts onboard were well prepared for
cases like this and have taken the
appropriate precautionary measures that
patients were isolated and received care
aboard the ship while working to
transfer patients as soon as practical
to the Javits Federal Medical station
which is treating kovaydin 19 patients
the comfort is capable of continuing its
mission about a dozen patients from the
Javits Center in Midtown were
transferred to the hospital ship Comfort
Friday one day after President Trump
approved New York Governor Cuomo's
requests to have Kovac patients treated
at the Javits Center all the non kovat
patients of the Javits Center were then
transferred to the hospital ship a short
distance away the original plan was for
comfort to relieve the burden on
hospital ships on hospitals by taking in
only trauma patients not kovat patients
so the local hospitals could focus on
the virus but half of people infected
with the virus now show no symptoms
according to the latest data comfort has
been more to peer 90 on Manhattan's West
Side since arriving Monday the US
military's top officer says that policy
of treating only non kovetz on patients
on board might change
we're reassessing that now and the
Secretary of Defense is making a risk
assessment to determine whether or not
we should take on all the kovat patients
to relieve some of the local hospitals
that decision is not imminent a pentagon
spokesman said here yesterday Leland